Hello, and welcome to our second video in the Introduction to Blueprints course.
In this, we're going to be jumping into the project
and having a look at the classes that are available to us
and how the interface works.
So to start with, we do not have a project file which comes with this course.
What we're going to be doing is we're going to be creating one from the templates which are available.
So I have the engine version 5.6 here.
I'm going to hit the launch button so that we can fire it up.
Now, once we're into the project, I want to pick the first person games template
and we're going to leave this set to Blueprints, the target desktop
and we just need to pick a folder and give the project a name
and then just hit create.
So it'll take you a couple of minutes to fire it up.
And then you should hopefully have something that looks a little bit like this.
Now, again, if we push play, we have to actually play this game
and that's going to allow us to move around in first person view.
It's relatively straightforward.
Now, what I would like to do is start off by right-hand clicking.
I'm going to create a blueprint class
and what it's going to do is it's going to ask us to pick a parent class.
We've already talked about what a parent and child class is
but this gives us a chance to see it within the engine.
Now, we have the actor class
and we have the pawn and the character class, three classes we've already talked about.
One of the things that's interesting is if you were to come down to the bottom here
and hit this drop down, this is going to show you all of the different classes
along with their inheritance.
So we can see here that we have object, which is the direct base class for all UE objects
and the hundreds and lots and lots of different child classes.
So, for example, we have actor, so we talked about actor.
This is the one that we can drag into the level.
Below that, we have loads of different classes
which are inherit from the actor class
and somewhere inside here will be character.
It's all in alphabetical order, so we shall find it.
The pawn, I think, is the actual inheritance.
So here we go, here we have pawn.
Under that, we have the character.
Under the character, we have even more versions.
We have a paper character, first person character, and so on.
So this is useful because it shows us every class which is within the system.
Now, we can have extra classes
by if we add in more content or plugins,
and we will be able to find this in the list as we go.
The time being, I'm just going to create an actor class.
I'm going to rename this BP underscore door.
I'm going to use this later on,
but once we've created this, double click on the BP door
and this will open up our class.
This gives us an opportunity to have a look at the interface.
So for the Blueprint interface, what we have here across the top
is our toolbar.
Now, this is a little bit different to some of the other ones.
There's a lot of very similar functionality here.
To start with, we have Save.
Just saves the asset or the work you've done to disk.
Next up, we have Browse To.
And this is useful because say we're in an odd directory here,
and I wanted to drag this into the world,
I could hit Browse To,
and it will automatically browse to that asset
and allow me to drag that into the world.
So that's the Browse To.
We have Compile.
Now, at the moment, the compile has a tick box by it,
and that means it is good to go.
It has successfully compiled.
However, if I was to come in and I'm just going to add something in quickly,
you will see that the Compile button now gives us a yellow question mark,
which says it's dirty and needs to be recompiled.
If I hit Compile, this runs fine.
So I'm going to find a node which didn't.
So, OK, here you go.
Add input vector, that calls.
Our third condition is this red mark here,
which says there was an error during compilation.
See log for details.
So this is your code has not compiled and it has broken.
You'll see down here in the compiling results at the bottom,
it will tell us about what the problem is.
In this case, the blueprints is not a form of movement component,
and therefore the target must have a connection.
So don't worry too much about that.
That means that this is an incorrect function for the actor class.
But it's just there as an example to show you what
the code compile looks like if it fails.
Next up, we have Difference.
Now this is part of source control.
Don't need to worry about it for this course,
but it will allow you to see what's been changed from one version to the next.
Fine, this will give you an option to search for a specific example.
Begin Play, help me move to the Begin Play node.
Hide unrelated.
I'll try and demonstrate that as we go on.
But how that works is I'm just going to drag a number of nodes in here.
If I have hide unrelated on, when I have a node selected,
it will grey out, make it slightly transparent,
any of the nodes which are not directly connected to the selected node.
So you can see at a glance what the logic flow is,
so you can debug something.
Class Settings and Class Defaults,
these are just the values that are assigned to the actor,
usually inherited from the parents.
Simulation, I'll try and demonstrate that in a second as well.
That will simulate within the actor any of the movement or anything that goes on.
And on the right here, these are quick buttons that will allow us to play in the level, for example.
And so this is a shortcut to the same input that we have at the top of the viewport.
Finally, here we have a dropdown for debugging.
What this is going to allow us to do, if I hit Play here,
or simulate,
you'll see, we can see for this instance,
we can see how the code is being fired.
Again, you can see this on Begin Play.
Again, this is very useful.
If you want to debug stuff, you can watch the code as it is firing,
and it'll give you an idea of what's happening.
So that's the toolbar.
I'll demonstrate the simulation in a little bit.
Next up, on the left here, we have the components.
Now, the components are the elements, the parts of this blueprint.
Now, at the moment, all we have is the default scene route.
But if I was to push Add, it would give me an option of all the different components,
which we could add to our actor.
So for example, I'll add a cube for starting.
Now, if I click onto the viewport, see that we have a cube.
Not all of the components need to be a visual.
Just in this case, I have the static mesh.
So for example, I was to add a rotating movement.
This provides functionality, but it does not provide anything visual.
Except for if I was to hit Simulate now,
you can see that this would rotate.
Now, in the middle,
on the left-hand side, we have a list of event graphs,
and functions, and variables.
Now, we're going to be going over them in detail
as we actually put stuff together.
But if you do come from a coding background,
this would be a bit like your header file or your code.
So it defines everything that we need, et cetera.
You also have functions here,
but you can see we have something that's called an override.
And this will allow us access to all of the functions
which are hearts of the parent and the parent classes.
In the center here, I've gone onto the tab for the viewport.
This is a visual representation
of what the actor will look like in the world.
Now, this functions in a very similar manner to our level viewport,
meaning if we hold down the right-hand key
with the AWS and D, we'll be able to move around.
Q&E will mess up and down.
We'll be able to control the camera speed
with the middle mouse button
and even focus on things if need be.
But it will allow us to select.
So the components is sort of like our world outliner.
And this is the viewport.
This is specific to the actor.
We then, we also have the event graph
and the construction script.
Now, these are going to be where we place the actual coding.
So we will look over those
as we get into the coding in the next video.
And the final section is on the right-hand side
is our details panel.
And again, our details panel,
much like the rest of the engine, is contextual.
So as you select different elements, such as nodes,
or even components, or even variables,
if we go to variable,
the details panel will give us the details
of that specific element.
So it'll allow us to edit things.
Now, before we finish this video,
I'd like to do one last thing to this project.
I'd like to pad in some extra assets.
Now, if you come back to the main screen,
see I've got the content browser up here.
This comes up by default for me.
We might not have that.
So if you press control and space,
it will bring up the content browser.
And I'm just going to dock it in the viewport.
Now, I would like to add some content.
We're going to need some meshes.
So I'm going to come up to add,
and then I'm going to come up to add feature or content pack.
I'm going to come across to the third tab for content
and select starter content.
Now, this is just a large collection of assets,
including props, tables, chairs, doors,
and some textures, and even some special effects.
We mainly want static meshes from this.
I'm going to click add to project,
and that will copy across a directory called starter content.
That should take us to the end of this video.
All our project now is completely set up,
and we should be ready to start doing some coding.